for 10 days these men have camped
outside the un's headquarters in Tunis
their Asylum Seekers from Sudan who were
hoping to make it to Europe some have
been waiting five years for their claims
to be processed
we're patient and stick together to find
a solution I appealed to the United
Nations European union and all
humanitarian organizations to help us
evacuate from Tunisia toward any other
safe country where we can settle in the
past tunisians welcome us but now they
reject our presence and want us to leave
according to Aid agencies there are 30
to 50 000 migrants from other regions of
Africa living in Tunisia without
documents last month president Kaya
Saeed caused controversy when he said
quote hordes of sub-Saharan Africans
were changing the demographic makeup of
the country it sparked racist attacks
throughout Tunisia
I have been in Tunisia for five years
and I have not seen anyone obtain asylum
in another country we do not have
protection in Tunisia they have taken
away our accommodation and there are
many other examples of violations
against black people the Tunisian
government does not want us here
rights groups have condemned the
president's comments as racist but in
the face of growing bigotry these Asylum
Seekers are urging the UN to help them
leave Tunisia as soon as possible
Victoria Gayton B Al Jazeera